(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm sick.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
you'll have to be listening
to me speak like this
and you know what, did
I bring my tissues in,
I didn't even bring my frickin' tissues.
- Oh gosh.
Can you, can somebody help
please get the tissues?
- There's a tissue box in our office
which I've been carrying
around with myself all day.
- Be careful with the dogs,
you'll let the dogs out.
- Don't let the dogs out.
- This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are going to get Rhett's tissues
and hopefully minimize him
talking because the more--
- Minimize me talking?
- Yeah 'cause the more
you talk, the more I can tell you're sick,
and the more you're spewing
stuff into my radius.
- No no I have been purposely directing it
away from you all day.
I'm currently speaking
out of the right side
of my mouth so it all goes
to one side of the room.
- Can you face that way?
Are you cool with that?
- Yeah I'm projecting
everything to this side.
- But also face that way.
- Thank you, Kiko.
Look at that, got my tissue box.
I'll sit it up there.
- Today we're gonna
update you and each other
on the spring break adventures we had.
We're two spring breakers.
- Yeah.
- We're not over 40.
We still go on spring
break with our children.
- Right.
- So yeah we had a full week off
that we have not fully
downloaded to each other.
I mean it's, from calendar
time it's the distant past,
but in relational time, it's yesterday.
- Yeah it's been--
- It's yesterday, brother.
- A week and a half or so.
We do wanna let you know
that your boys have been
nominated for a couple of Webbys.
For your favorite or at least
the podcast you're listening
to right now, Ear Biscuits.
Yes, we are a Webby nominee in podcasts.
Best host which I think is me but...
- I think that's me.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, it actually said in parentheses,
the shorter one.
- So you can go to--
- The funnier one.
- If you wanna vote for me
or Link as best host--
- No.
So we're--
- They don't have a
best host category.
- You shouldn't make us
compete against each other.
We're competing against other people.
- No, the whole idea is
that people compete against,
we compete against each
other to generate more votes
for us collectively 'cause what
we're not telling everybody
is that a vote for me is a vote for us
and a vote for you is a vote for us.
So vote twice.
- You can vote because
there's an audience choice
and we want you to choose
us, vote.webbyawards.com
through April 18th, 2019.
- But that was just one
of the nominations, Link.
The other nomination was just best podcast
in the comedy category.
- Yeah very honored, thank
you Webbys for the nomination.
Listen, we don't have much
control over the judge's choices
but we can encourage you to vote.
- We are part of the academy.
- Vote.webbyawards.com.
- And we will be voting for ourselves.
- Look only for Ear Biscuits,
and GMM is also nominated.
- Can you do that, can
you vote for yourself?
- GMM was nominated for
variety series, comedy, and...
Is that all we got?
GMM hosts, we got a honorable mention.
- Yeah yeah we're not good enough--
- We didn't quite make it.
- Hosts of GMM to be a nominee
but we're good enough to be an honoree.
- And all we do is go on vacations
and come back and talk about it.
(Rhett laughs)
I mean and then you call it comedy.
- That's right.
- It's the new comedy.
- Hold on, you know what, that's a great--
- You think it's better than,
that's not what you call it, Feldman?
- Sorry to touch your sleeve.
- Don't touch my sleeve.
We're gonna have to desanitize it.
- But you just actually--
- Well sanitize it.
- You gave me and us--
- A quarter?
- An idea for what the future
of this podcast could be.
Let's just be travel buddies
and just talk about our travels.
- Yeah, okay.
Can we go separate?
(Rhett laughs)
Because if we go together
there's nothing to talk about.
- You're right, yeah,
yeah I see where you're going with that.
- Can we be estranged travel buddies?
- We go, we're not travel buddies,
we're travel correspondents.
- You need to raise your mic a little bit.
I think Smosh has been
using your mic stand
and you're hunching.
- You're not supposed to
tell people that Smosh
records their podcast in here.
- And you're gonna make 'em sick.
- Yeah, that's my goal, make Smosh sick.
- That's not strategic for us.
I'm just gonna be honest.
So I went back to London for spring break
and we took, I had this idea in January,
maybe it was the end of last year.
I had this idea because
Lily, our oldest daughter,
our oldest child, is turning 16.
Well she just did, March
31st, she turned 16.
And I was thinking, wouldn't it be cool
to just take her on a vacation just us,
me, Christy and her, so
it's not a family vacation.
This is like a dedicated time to just
make it special for her at such
a special point in her life.
I mean they call it sweet 16.
- For a reason.
- Well question mark.
So I would like to explore at
some point how sweet it was.
There were a couple of acute sour points
which I will get into.
- Oh, exciting.
- And it's, I don't know,
I'm still processing.
Allow me to process with
you so I will give some
London recommendations
on my second trip there
in just a number of weeks.
- And I will use those.
And I of course went to a different part
of the world, closer, I
went to Colorado and skied
and had some harrowing experiences there.
Wouldn't say I almost
died, at least that I--
- You had heroin in Vail.
- At least not as, I didn't
come as close to death,
you know, sometimes you
never know how close
you got to death, I mean
maybe I just missed death,
but I embarrassed myself in
a big way a couple of times.
- Again, we will know when we die
and watch the footage back--
- Right.
- How close you came to death.
I don't know if I'll be there though.
Travel, estranged travel buddies,
we're not gonna die at the same time.
- That's the name of it,
Estranged Travel Buddies
is the name of the podcast.
I do wanna tell you about
another travel thing
that happened to me
just two days ago.
So--
- Do it.
- For those of you who read
the Book of Mythicality,
or came to the Tour of
Mythicality, you know the story
that I tell about my
wife's grandmother, Gaga,
and her integral sort of very funny role
in our relationship of
emailing back and forth.
- You should tell a truncated version.
- Basically she had an email
address back in the 90s
when I was getting to know
Jessie and Jessie did not
so I literally emailed her
grandmother who would then
print out the emails and
then send them to Jessie.
- Because you were in Slovakia.
- 'Cause I was in a different place.
And I tell that story in
the Book of Mythicality
and on the tour but anyway,
Gaga at the age of 94
passed away last week.
Well a little more than a week ago.
- I was sad to hear that.
- And we went home for--
- Great woman.
- A memorial service.
And I already knew that she
was an incredible woman.
I knew that she was, like I told you,
that she was like strangely
great, like unusually unusual.
She kinda fit the typical
older southern lady
in a certain number of
ways but she also was just,
the things that you--
- She would say like southern--
- She dropped her Rs.
- She talked like--
- Yeah it was like that old
southern belle kinda thing.
But like something is up in the ay-ah.
You know, she literally talked like that
and she was not joking.
- Yeah.
- This old Raleigh accent.
But as we told stories about her, we just,
all these things came back--
- Was that the ceremony,
like a storytelling--
- Yeah it was literally, we just--
- That's cool.
- All got together
at her daughter's house, my mother-in-law,
and we just told stories about
her and we all wore white.
She was like I don't
want y'all to wear black.
I want you to wear white
'cause it's a celebration.
I lived 94 years, and so anyway, it was,
there was lots of laughs, lots
of funny stories about Gaga,
lots of tears at the same time.
But anyway I had to make a very quick trip
to North Carolina for the weekend.
Took the red eye on Friday night.
There's actually an airport in New Bern.
- Yeah.
- Which is not too far
from where your wife grew up.
- Down east.
- And that's a lot closer, 'cause we,
it was actually at my in-law's beach house
is where we had the
ceremony so I was like well,
this is a quick trip, I'm
gonna fly directly to New Bern
and then rent a car and
go down to the beach house
and I was gonna fly, flew on Friday night.
- We filmed all day.
- Yeah yeah yeah, so
yeah, we were shooting GMM
and some other things on Friday
and so we went pretty late
so I took that red eye
which incidentally was one
of the red eyes where I was
hoping that I was gonna have
a little bit more room
but I basically just sat
in an upright position and tried to sleep
which was not fun, it's not fun
for a big man to have to do that.
- Tell that to a horse.
- Believe it's one of the
reasons that I got sick
'cause I didn't get a lot of sleep
and I was already getting sick, anyway,
beautiful ceremony on
Saturday and then Sunday
we're gonna go back and of course we have
to go to the New Bern airport.
Then you take a flight from New Bern
to Charlotte, North Carolina--
- Like a puddle jumper situation?
- I mean it wasn't, yeah,
it was a small, small plane.
Bigger than I anticipated
but still pretty small.
One row of seats and then
two rows, one column of seats
and then two columns of seats
on each side of the plane.
And so we get to the New Bern airport
which incidentally is like two gates
and there are--
- Like a strip mall
type situation?
- It looks like you're pulling
into a retirement home.
- Oh.
Even better.
- That's what the airport is like.
Like literally the rental car
drop off is just a parking lot
and it's for all the companies.
And then when you go
inside, no matter what
the rental car company is, you
deal with the Alamo person.
So there's a sign on the
Enterprise thing that says,
we're out, please talk
to Alamo. (chuckles)
- Oh wow.
- So like,
they got one employee
handling all the rental cars.
There's rocking chairs in the
airport which incidentally
there's rocking chairs
in the Charlotte airport.
But it's much more quaint
than the New Bern airport
which I think is called Coastal
Carolina Regional Airport.
- Are you sure you weren't
flying out of a Cracker Barrel?
- (chuckles) It was as
much like a Cracker Barrel
as an airport can be.
- Okay.
I hope to be successful enough
to park my private plane
at Cracker Barrels.
- It's so small
that you don't just get there
and then go through security,
you get there and you sit outside
and then right before
your plane takes off,
they're like okay, everybody
go through security.
Then you go through security
and just basically get
on the plane, that's how small it is.
So Locke and I get there,
I got there like an hour before the flight
which is very late for me typically,
you know what I'm saying,
I'm at 1.5 to two hours ahead of time
but I knew that we didn't
have a lot to deal with.
- And you're still an anxious wreck.
- And I get there an hour
early and then I realize
that the flight has been
delayed by 30 minutes
which is gonna give us about 30 minutes
to make our connection.
From the time the doors,
we touch down in Charlotte.
We got about 30 minutes
before they shut the door,
so I'm a little anxious.
Anything could go wrong
here, sitting there waiting,
and then the flight gets delayed.
Now we get onto the runway
and the pilot says, "I, unfortunate news,
"we've been given a weather delay.
"We're gonna take off in
approximately 30 minutes."
- That's not gonna work.
- So basically my entire buffer--
- Yeah.
- Is gone.
So first thing I do--
- Could have stayed
in that rocking chair.
- First thing I do
because I have become
basically totally dependent
on people helping me do things
at this point in my life--
(Link chuckles)
Is I text Jenna, my
assistant, our assistant.
- Oh gosh.
- And I'm like, Jenna.
(sighs)
Here's the situation,
I actually called her.
I called her, I was like,
okay, we were supposed
to have a buffer, we're not
gonna have a buffer and--
- I just need a shoulder
to cry on right now.
- I need you to--
- Through the phone.
- I need you to get me on the next flight.
I talked to the woman at the
gate in New Bern preemptively
and she was like well the
next flight's completely full.
You could do standby or you
could fly out in the morning
and I'm just thinking about the fact
that I don't wanna be there,
I'm with Locke by the way
so Locke and I flew together 'cause Jessie
and Shepherd were staying
a couple days extra.
Locke's gotta get back to school,
I gotta get back to work,
we got things happenin',
we got things scheduled,
we got meetings, et cetera.
- You're important enough
to have an assistant.
- And so,
she was like okay I'll
get on the phone with the,
actually the representative
is supposed to call me back
in 50 minutes because that's what,
when she called the
number, they were like,
to get a call back 50 minutes
from now, so she did that.
And that's about how long the flight takes
so we touch down, mathematically speaking,
and I had talked to the pilot.
I'd gone up to the two pilots
'cause everybody's sitting with each other
and I start talking with them with like--
- Hold on, you were
sittin' with the pilots.
- The pilots were sitting
waiting to get on the plane.
- Oh.
- Waiting to get on the plane
and I was like hey guys,
how confident are you
in this getting to Charlotte?
And they were like younger than me and so,
and they were like, well, you know,
it'll probably be one hour total
from closing the doors
to opening the doors.
Getting off the next
plane and they were like,
where you gotta get?
I was like I got a really
tight connection to LAX
and they're like okay
we'll do whatever we can
to get there as fast as we, like,
I don't know what kind
of control they have.
I thought it was all autopilot anyway.
- What'd you think, they
might say, you know what,
we'll just take you to Los Angeles.
- Yeah I was hoping for that.
- I've seen you on the internet.
- We'll reroute the plane.
- I think you're nominated
for a Webby, hey,
do you have an assistant?
- That was what I was hoping for secretly.
- All right we're going
straight to Los Angeles.
- I was hoping they would
secretly recognize me
and make accommodations
but that didn't happen.
So anyway, I was freaking
out as you might imagine
and then we, our flight out
of Charlotte was at 5:45.
The plane lands, now we've
been told they close the doors
10 minutes before departure,
5:35, the doors will close.
We landed, we touched down
on the runway at 5:25.
It took seven minutes for them to--
- You got three minutes to get there.
- But not only that, because
the plane is so small,
we had to valet our bags
so we couldn't just get off the plane.
They had to put the bags
with the tags underneath,
gate check the bags.
- Okay.
- So--
- How much time did you have
when you got your bags?
- One minute.
- Okay.
- We had one minute.
We got our bags at 5:34.
I'm texting Jenna, she's
like, the woman says
that you're not gonna make it.
She's talked to the gate,
they're not holding.
They're not holding it for you.
That's what Jenna's saying
that the American Airlines
woman is saying to her.
She's like I've already got
you booked on the next flight.
- I think they did know who you were.
- They've already got you
booked on the next flight.
So first of all, I looked at
a map of the Charlotte airport
and I was all the way
at the end of terminal D
or E, I had to go all the way down E
and then back up D.
- You're trying to
Jason Bourne this thing.
- All the way down E and back up D.
And I'm looking at the
thing, I'm like okay,
maybe I can make this.
I was thinking maybe I could
make this in five minutes
when I had one minute, I was already sick.
Anyway, Locke and I pick up our carry ons.
We're literally carrying our carry ons
and we both have backpacks.
We start running, Locke's a young man.
He's 15, he's in shape.
He kinda gets ahead of me pretty quickly.
I'm running as fast as I possibly can
without hurting myself
through the Charlotte airport.
- Wow.
- Saying, "Excuse me,
"excuse me, excuse me,
excuse me, excuse me."
Being as polite as possible,
still a good southern boy.
- I would have just resorted to a beep.
Boop, boop, boop!
- Then they just think you're backing up.
They think, "Excuse the
cart," when you do that
and then they'd get out
of the way slowly.
- They would have
looked for a cart.
- Just flying through the airport.
Eventually I had to
stop and gather myself.
- Oh.
- I mean it was that crazy.
- Let's take a breather,
hands on the knees.
- Multiple, so in the
end I stopped three times
and we get all the way to the gate
and I see a bunch of people
lined up and I'm like
this is potentially really good news?
And then the guy sees us
run up, this dude is like,
they changed it to six
o'clock guys, no worries.
- Shh, really?
- They moved it back 15 minutes
so they had already boarded
my group so I'm like sweating profusely.
I've got a hoodie on that
I've worn and ran in.
- Oh gosh.
- And anyway, I think
that sent me even further
into sickness because I just
completely exerted myself.
That's the most I've worked
out in probably a decade,
it was just to run across
the Charlotte airport
and you know what, I could have strolled
'cause I had 15 minutes instead of one.
- I would have said, you know what,
I'd rather not worry about
this and I wouldn't have done,
I mean I'm not rubbing it
in I'm just telling you,
I would have not done anything.
I would have been like well,
I'll get there when I get there.
But ironically I would have gotten there
the same time as you.
- And nine times
out of 10, you would
have missed the flight.
- Oh that's your opinion.
- And I would have missed the flight.
If they hadn't moved the flight--
- If I was there we would--
- I would have missed it.
- Have gotten in a huge fight.
I would have just, I
probably wouldn't have ran.
- I would have gotten on
the plane without you.
- Yeah I probably wouldn't have ran.
I probably would have ran
but I would have been very angry about it
and then I would have been
proven right when we got there.
- What did Locke say, was he mad?
- No, he was excited, it was an adventure.
- Well he's not 41.
He didn't almost pull something or die.
- Kiko, could you grab that
trash can so I don't have
to throw my snot-laden
tissues onto the floor?
- And then Jenna did all
this work for nothing.
Now Kiko's doing this, look at you, man.
Look at you, man.
(Rhett sighs)
- Anyway--
- Can't get your own Kleenex,
can't get your own trash can.
- If you need the directions from gate E38
to gate D10 at Charlotte
just hit me up on Twitter.
That's @rhettmc.
- I bet you smelled horrible.
- No I smelled good.
- You actually didn't.
- My sweat tends to generate good odors.
- Oh gosh, listen at you man.
Listen atcha.
- Listen at you.
- I'm gonna share my experience
and then hear about yours.
But first, we gotta promote
some stuff, some merch.
Mythical.store, it's where you
can get all types of stuff.
Big and small.
Here's a small thing.
A popsocket that says, it's
got the Mythical logo on it.
- I got a popsocket--
- That's our company.
- That has the Good
Mythical Morning logo on it.
- So if you want a little something like
a mid-year stocking stuffer,
like get the jump on
stuffing that socking.
At Mythical.store.
You'll forget that it was in there.
You're like wow, I've already, fill it up.
- Listen to that satisfying
sound that a popsocket makes.
- Fill it halfway up. (popsocket pops)
We got stickers, we got all
types of stuff, rep ya boys.
That's okay, we didn't need that anymore.
- Sorry.
- (sighs) Anything else you wanna promote?
We got a store on Amazon
too, you can check that out.
It's got different types of t-shirts, psh.
All types of stuff happenin', yeah.
Okay.
I think our spring break
vacations were like polar opposite
because I did something
that I'm not used to doing
and then this will play out,
me not being used to this
over the course of the
specifics of my story
but we didn't go on
what I call a vacation,
we went on a sight-seeing trip of London.
Lily had the choice, she
wanted to go to London.
I think predominantly because
she's a Harry Potter fan.
And then, I just think she's a fan
of like British programming.
I mean she went through a Doctor Who phase
and the Sherlock Benedict
Cumberbatch type situation.
So I can't fault her for liking
that British comedic sensibility
and storytelling panache.
So I was like, you
know, I missed the whole
Harry Potter boat but
maybe there isn't a boat,
I don't know.
- There's probably a boat
in one of the stories.
- They don't have any boats
in Harry Potter I don't think.
They got broomsticks.
- You gotta have a boat
for something.
- Just broomsticks.
And a train, trains and sticks, not boats.
- Oh.
- But I'm like, you know
what, this is for you.
Okay, we knew she was gonna choose London.
I basically booked the trip,
got the Airbnb in Lisson Grove
which is an area of London,
it's pretty centrally-located,
close to the Tube.
- Like Listen Grove?
- L-I-S-S-O-N.
And you know so a nice little
Airbnb, a little bed for her
and then another bedroom
for me and Christy.
Full kitchen, all this type of vibe.
So we got our own space.
But it was much more a
sight-seeing trip than a vacation,
'cause there's no relaxing.
It's like what are we gonna do next
and what are we gonna see next?
We had booked going to the
Warner Bros. Studio Tour
where they filmed all
the Harry Potter movies
and they have all the
actual props and costuming
and detailed set pieces
and all types of things
from all of the movies.
So we booked that ahead of time.
On another day we also booked
tickets to the stage play
from the world of Harry
Potter called Cursed Child.
Which I remember a couple of years back,
she bought the, we bought her the script.
I was like okay is this
another Harry Potter book?
No it's just the script.
So we got our hands on tickets for that.
There's a two hour show
and then there's a break,
I mean there's intermission
in the middle of that
and then you come back
later and there's two,
basically two more hours so
it's two different plays.
- That's a lot of play.
- But it's one story so
you gotta kinda go all in.
- It was about like two
hours too much play for me.
- I was nervous.
- Maybe 2.5 hours too much.
- I mean I may come back
to it but I will say that
having done everything
that I could list out
that we did, it was a highlight.
I really enjoyed it, it's
one of my favorite days
was when we did that.
We saw the first play, first two hours,
and then we took a break, walked around
and we went to Dishoom.
Our favorite place when we went to London.
- Very good.
- I went to a different one
and it was just as amazing.
I am actually calling it
my favorite restaurant now.
- You're calling it your
favorite restaurant.
- Yeah I mean it's--
- Better than Slug and Lettuce?
- Yeah.
And then we went back--
- Whoa.
- For the other part of it
and it was really well done,
it wasn't a musical.
Which, I think side stepped
a bunch of potential
pot holes so to speak.
- There's that much time,
oh intermission such that
you can eat a dinner?
- No.
There was intermission in the
middle of the two hour play
and then there were like, you
go out for two and a half,
three hours, then you come back
and watch another two hour play.
- Right so it's a long break.
- Yeah, the intermission was
just a 15 minute bathroom break
in the middle of each play.
- Got it.
- Two part story.
- Yeah so that,
I mean, day three was our studio tour.
Day four was Cursed Child, so day one,
just to kinda rattle
off the things we did,
we took the Tube to Westminster
Abbey but it was a Sunday
so we couldn't get inside,
I didn't realize that
so I'm like ooh, that's my bad.
It started hailing.
It was cold.
Like literally, it was the
only day that I saw sun
the whole time I was there.
I was like that is a
scarce commodity in London.
The solar thing, solar ball in the sky.
- Solar ball in the sky.
- The only day I saw it,
it was also hailing on me.
So I had to adjust my
plan instead of like going
to Piccadilly Circus and,
we missed the changing of
the guard, got hailed on.
I'm like man, this is not a
good start on a first full day.
And then I was like it's too cold.
I was like we gotta go
into the British Museum.
Saw the Rosetta Stone,
which, that's pretty awesome.
I didn't realize that
according to what I read there,
at least, maybe they're
puffing themselves up too much
but if it wasn't for the Rosetta Stone,
we would not know how to
translate Egyptian hieroglyphics.
Period.
- We also wouldn't have
those great infomercials late
at night about--
- Which is why they exist right?
- The software.
- There's three different
languages on there
and then each language says
that hey, this is written
in two other languages, it
says this is the same thing
written in three different languages,
so whichever language
you read, you know that.
And that's how they
deciphered hieroglyphics.
I also saw one of the Easter Island dudes.
They just got sitting in there.
- The British--
- That was pretty cool.
- The British have had a
tendency to just go places
and steal things and then bring
'em back to their museums.
- There's nothing British
in the British Museum.
(Rhett laughs)
I mean there's like
hunks of the Parthenon.
It was awesome, but yeah you
do get this weird feeling
and like, I heard people joking about it,
about how nothing there is
British and I guess I mean,
I stole that joke which wasn't that great.
(both chuckle)
- I got this joke from
the people at the museum.
- Nothing there in the
British museum is British.
We were there for like an hour and then,
we ended up going, we
went on the London Eye,
the big Ferris wheel.
Christy didn't do that.
You're developing a
flavor profile of my wife.
She doesn't like to fly but she did it.
She conquered her fear,
it was a long flight.
She conquers her fear every
single time she flies,
so big ups to Christy.
But she did not elect
to go on the London Eye.
And I wasn't gonna,
you choose your battles
and that wasn't it.
Christy and I, Lily and I did that.
- Well when you talk about these things,
you need to tell me,
you need to give me the,
I recommend that or I don't recommend that
because I mean I'm gonna be in London
in August and you know.
- I recommend the British Museum.
I wouldn't do the top 10 audio tour
because they kinda send
you around to every part
of the museum and that's what we did.
It was very cool so we
kinda got a whirlwind tour
but I would recommend
that you look at the types
of things that you're interested in
and just choose one or two and go there.
Instead of trying to do the top
10 because there were things
that I weren't quite as
interested in even though
just for the sake of them wanting
to take me around the whole museum.
If you want a good place
to eat in Shoreditch,
we ended up that first night
at a place called Gloria
which had amazing pizza.
Like really good pizza, really good vibe.
I think there's one in Paris
and then they just opened
this one in London and--
- Do you meet Gloria?
- No but they had records playing
and the ceiling was mirrored.
It was really cool, the
downstairs was awesome.
- Is the London Eye worth it or is it--
- I don't think so.
- It doesn't feel worth it
to me--
- I went at night,
it didn't feel worth it.
I don't think it's worth it.
- I could imagine.
- Yeah.
- I could imagine
what it feels like, what it looks like.
- It's very slow, it's not, ah, you know.
- It's not the Zipper.
- It's missable.
- It's not the Ring of Fire.
- And then on day two, we
get up I'm like all right,
we got our Oyster card from the Tube,
I'm like we gotta get back on the Tube.
I think what Christy
didn't tell me was that
part of the fear of flying
is the confined space
type situation so she wasn't really
in love with the Tube either.
I'm definitely not criticizing
her because I mean,
there's some actual
anxiety going on in there,
it's something that
like, I don't experience
so it's hard for me to empathize
but I'm definitely not
gonna fall for the trap
of making fun of it.
(chuckles)
- Okay, then I will. (chuckles)
- But so I'm like all right
let's get back on the Tube.
We're gonna go to the Tower of London.
We got the Harry Potter
stuff, just hold out,
we'll get there tomorrow,
let's just get this,
let's get this tourist
stuff out of the way
that everybody does.
And I'm kinda stressin'
out 'cause I'm like,
it's taking me to different stops
and Google maps are really
good at showing you which one
to get on but like, then the train,
it says it's about to pull
up and it says something
a little bit different, and I'm like,
I think this is it, let's
get on and then you get on
and then you're like,
I'm starting to panic.
And I'm like this is not the right one.
And I'm like it's not
the right one and stop it
at the first stop and I'm like--
- Get off!
- We gotta get off.
We gotta get off and we
were still like above ground
at another platform.
- Uh-oh.
- And I'm like this
is, I looked at the map
where we were then, I was like, yeah,
we went the wrong direction.
And now it's saying we gotta
go and we can't just get
on another train here
and I'm like in full panic mode.
Like--
(Rhett laughs)
I actually was like falling
apart and I didn't realize it.
I was panicking and
I'm like, we gotta get,
'cause getting on a train and
then making a split decision
to get off and make sure that all members
of your family are there.
Boy I'm glad I didn't
have the boys with me.
I guarantee you at least
one of 'em would still be
on that Tube right now.
(chuckles)
So we're on the platform--
- It'd be a good experience.
- And Christy's like, I think,
I'm like listen, we gotta,
you gotta get on this,
we gotta go down here, we
gotta go on this platform,
we gotta get on another train and we'll go
in a totally different direction now
because we're gonna be
late and she's like,
why don't we just go up these
stairs and we could just Uber.
And I'm like no!
We can't Uber!
I've got this card!
I've invested in an Oyster card!
I'm like, I'm not yelling at
Christy, I'm yelling at London.
- Okay, yep.
- Okay?
I'm yelling at myself I
think is what was happening.
I was just freaking out and I was like,
no we have to, we can do this.
And like I can do this, I can, I can,
I can navigate.
I can get us there and it--
- What was your daughter
doing at this point?
- And she was like, she
was trying to be helpful.
She was looking on her phone
and trying to figure out
which train to get on because apparently,
this is very important to me.
And I said, "We can't take an Uber."
I am just, and I'm looking at the phone
and I'm trying to figure
it out and she's suggesting
an alternate plan and I'm like,
I'm gonna throw this
phone onto the tracks.
And I like, at that point I locked eyes
with Christy and I could tell that like,
she could see that something was--
- Snapping.
- Snapping inside of me
and it was just like,
then she was like quiet.
I looked at Lily and she looked in my eyes
and she was like quiet and I was like,
let's get an Uber.
(Rhett laughs)
But it was interesting
how, and then we get
to the Tower of London,
I'm thinking like, man,
I'm trying to explain myself
and like listen, it said it was gonna be
a 20 minute subway ride or,
they don't use the word subway.
- Oh that's your problem.
- 30 minute--
- Calling it the wrong thing.
- Uber.
And it was, we'd already
bought these and the price
and all this stuff and
it's like all this stuff
that doesn't matter, I was
just trying to make myself,
I was trying to explain
myself and try to restore
what I felt like was
the hope that was lost
in my girl's eyes that I could lead us
to the Tower of London,
the place where queens
were beheaded or whatever.
- Did you, I doubt that, did you--
- Oh they beheaded grandmas.
I took the tour, brother.
They beheaded--
- Queens though?
- A king and a king's mom.
- But did you make it on
time, did you miss your tour?
- Well a tour leaves every 30 minutes.
- Okay.
- So again it's like--
- It was okay.
- I was freaking out
over nothing but it was like,
it was a bad Uber ride there,
I will say that.
It was like--
- This is day two.
- Yeah, morning of day two.
- Yeah can't have this kind of,
you can't fall apart on day two.
- We get out of the
Uber and Christy's like
we're just gonna go get a coffee.
I'm like well I'm gonna go get the tickets
and then I'm like, I had some space and I,
you know, I just needed
a couple of minutes
to realize that I was being a jackass.
- Well you know falling
apart on day two, actually,
there is a different way to see that.
Get it out of the way, as
long as you don't fall out,
you don't freak out again.
- We did the tour, the tour was fun.
We saw the Crown Jewels in a rack.
- I always thought that
those were testicles.
- Yeah.
- They're not.
- What do you think the rack is?
- I thought those were breasts.
(Link chuckles)
(Rhett chuckles)
- Crown Jewels are you know, for--
- It's not the king's nuts.
- It's king's jewels.
It's literally jewels, Rhett.
It's not a euphemism
for anything, you dirty.
- No, I just.
Yeah, oh that's the family jewels.
The family jewels.
- Yeah the Crown Jewels
go in the crown.
- Yeah.
- And there's all these
different crowns and scepters
and I kinda, I wasn't that into it,
but you get on a--
- You don't like gems?
- I don't like gems.
I don't like crowns,
I don't like scepters.
- Whoa.
- And there's a bunch of 'em
and you get on a moving
platform and walk past--
- I gotta take your birthday present back.
- Stand--
(Rhett chuckles)
You stand and you're
escalated down past 'em,
but then you go to where
they would torture people
and they had a rack in there and I'm like,
this was down in the castle barracks part.
I'm like man, this is visceral,
this is where it's at.
There was one where they would,
picture if you get down on
your knees so your shins are
on the ground and then you put your belly
on top of your thighs and
you fold your whole self over
like you're in the fetal
position but on your shins.
- Sounds awesome.
- And then they put
a rack over top of you that
fits over the top of your back
and it comes together like this
and that part starts wrenching down
and they just start wrenching you down,
like scrunching you down on yourself.
So it's the opposite of a rack which like
pulls you apart, pulls
all your joints apart.
And they did this to
people, both of these.
- (sighs) I've been to the
Torture Museum in Prague.
- Oh gosh, I mean I saw two apparati.
- I saw many.
- I'm not into that, man.
I mean I was into two but
I couldn't be into three.
- I like seeing the
lengths that humans depravity can get to.
Not because I'm interested
in it for myself
but because it's just to
remind yourself of how
screwed up people are.
- Well if you would have seen
me on that platform saying,
"I'm gonna throw my
phone onto the tracks!"
Like when we got back into the
car after the tour of London,
which we had a good time,
the Beefeaters take you on the tour
and they're very boisterous
and they're funny.
And so I was like okay
this could be behind us.
The rest of our day could be, you know.
We got into another Uber
and it was hard to get into,
we weren't going back on the Tube.
And then we were Ubering to Camden Market
and we couldn't meet up
with the Uber and like,
I'm starting to wig out again.
And I realize that I had
all these expectations
that we were gonna see all these things
and everything was gonna go perfectly
and everything was gonna go
smoothly and it was up to me.
Like Christy and Lily,
they never put that on me.
I put that on myself but I'm just,
I have this perfectionistic way
of thinking that was very
self-destructive in that moment.
And so when we were back in the Uber,
I still couldn't, it was like
I was back in that place again
after the tour and it
was quiet and Christy,
she broke the ice and I was like,
I was trying to explain myself
again and I was just like,
I thought I was gonna
have a second breakdown.
It was just like, but this
time because I realized
that I was carrying all
this unnecessary weight
of a perfect, successful
trip being on my shoulders
that no one placed there except myself.
So once I got over that,
Camden Market was awesome
'cause there was some really good food.
You would love it there,
you should go there.
There's like a bunch of
different food trucks
and like all different
combinations of foods
but that was my first
moment of introspection.
I think it's good to have a couple
which I did have a second
one which I'll tell you
about after hearing a
little about Colorado
but I made it through that.
- Well I embarrassed myself as well.
- Oh good.
- I'm gonna tell ya a story that will,
you'll see the purpose in
it, it's a little back story.
- Okay.
- So as I established weeks ago,
I took the very douche baggish step
of getting custom ski
boots made for myself.
- You told us all about those boots.
- And I have an unusually shaped foot.
It's narrow, it's long, it's a high arch.
Ski boots that you just
get at the real place,
they just, they can't handle my feet.
- Your arch is so high it
looks like it was put in
one of those torture devices.
- Yeah, it might have been, I don't know.
- Which I think women call a high heel.
- I don't remember my early childhood.
- Like your foot bent over on itself.
- So I had these boots made and
then when I went to Mammoth,
the trip that I talked about before,
I actually ended up
with quite a bit of pain
in my heels, like the sides of my heels
in specifically the right
foot was very painful.
The outside of the right foot.
- Okay.
- So I go back to the
place in Studio City.
SkiNet Sports.
I didn't know the name last
time but shout out to Claude.
SkiNet Sports, he'll hook you up.
- But will he?
- Yeah, well yeah because
here's what he does.
You can never guarantee if a
boot's gonna have a perfect fit
until you go out and play
around in it, you know.
Ski in it as they say. (chuckles)
And I go back and I show him on my feet
where it's hurting and
then he takes this makeup,
he takes my socks, he says,
"Take your socks off,"
he doesn't do that for you
and then he puts makeup
on your feet and you put
them back in the boots
and then he has you push
your foot back into the back
of the boot and then it's basically,
you've pointed to where it
hurts, he's put makeup on there,
and then it shows inside the boot exactly
where that spot is
hurting and it turns out
you've got a little, he
showed me like a diagram
of a skeleton of the bones of the foot.
And there's this little bone
on the outside of your heel
that juts out, for a lot of
people, hat can be painful,
and so he goes, takes the boot.
I thought he was gonna melt
the boot, like move it around
but he actually just took
a little sander thing
and went in and ground down--
- Like a Dremel?
- Yeah, he ground it down.
- I could have done that.
- And created a pocket for
that bone on both feet.
- This is great.
- So I'm like so ready--
- You're set now.
- So ready to ski.
As I'm leaving, I'm like,
it's supposed to rain in Vail.
He said, "Well, you know what that means."
I was like what, he said,
"It won't." (chuckles)
Because he was like, the
weather forecast always changes
right before you get there.
He said, "But just in case,
take a couple of these,"
and he gives me this
little, it's like a ring
that looks like a little
flipper, like a foot flipper
but he said it's a little
windshield wiper for if it rains
to wipe the rain off of your goggles.
- You got a finger--
- Yeah.
- Windshield wiper?
- He's like one for you
and one for the lady.
And I was like well, I didn't tell him
my wife wasn't gonna ski but I was like
I'll take both of them, whatever.
Okay so, so Jessie was not gonna ski.
Jessie was like, I'm gonna
read, I'm gonna go around
and hang out in coffee shops,
I'm gonna eat, whatever,
I'm gonna have a great time.
- Okay.
- But me and Locke and Shepherd were going
to ski the whole time.
Like we're there for seven
days, we were gonna ski for six.
We're gonna have one day off.
(sniffles)
First day, it had snowed
a bunch the week before.
But it was perfectly
sunny, Claude was right.
The forecast changed.
No rain in the forecast
except for the last day.
Basically a week of sun.
- Okay.
- You haven't skied in
Colorado at all, right?
- Never.
- You've done Park City
which is an incredible
resort so you've kind
of experienced that but it was also,
there was a blizzard when we skied.
To ski in Colorado on a,
one of the best years
they've ever had in Vail
that's like a 400 inch
base and it's sunny.
(wind blowing)
Moving away from me.
Apparently he's not in
the mood for a closeup.
Missed opportunity, buddy.
It was absolutely incredible,
I mean there were moment
where I was just like,
I don't do like the crazy double
black diamonds or anything.
I'm like a blue man, the Blue Man Group,
and I just kinda take it easy.
- You like making things
into a percussion--
- Yeah and I just kinda
keep it easy, I just carve,
I like to get not too fast
'cause I don't wanna hurt myself.
- Yeah.
- Just having a great time.
- This is not an airport.
- And I'm having so much
fun and it's so expansive.
But about an hour and a half into skiing--
- My heel starts to hurt.
- I'm like, man.
- Claude.
- I had a feeling that Claude
had not quite gotten it--
- Jean-Claude Van--
- (chuckles) Not quite
Dremeled out enough of that.
He could have made a bigger
hole for my big ol' bone.
(chuckles)
- Okay.
- But he didn't and so
I'm hurtin' a little bit
but you know what I'm like,
you know what, you know
maybe you gotta break 'em in
a little bit, maybe
that's what you gotta do.
Maybe you gotta break
the boots in a little bit
once they get adjusted.
Well lunch rolls around and
we decide to meet Jessie
at a restaurant 'cause first of all,
highly recommend Vail.
I'll tell you the only
reason I don't recommend Vail
and I'll get into a story
later that illustrates this,
it's too expensive.
It's just, they have you trapped there.
They charge you too much for
everything but it's beautiful.
- Mm-hmm.
- And the village,
basically you ski right
down to the village
and you just put your skis
up and then you just walk
to a restaurant, meet your
wife who doesn't have skis on.
- You can walk in your skis boots?
- Well I can.
- 'Cause they're custom.
- No anybody can walk in their ski boots.
I mean it's awkward but yeah, yeah.
But Claude told me, he said,
"You keep these strapped down
"the whole day."
You don't have to, with rental boots,
a lot of times you have to let 'em loose
while you walk around.
He said, "These should fit
so tight and so perfectly,
"You just keep 'em down the whole day."
So I'm trying to do that, you
know, I wanna be a purist.
I wanna do what the guy tells me to do.
And as I walk into the restaurant,
I'm like my foot is hurting,
my heel is hurting me
maybe, maybe dare I say worse
than it did the first time,
before he made the adjustments.
- Okay.
- And I sit down, we have
lunch at this restaurant.
I have to take my boot off
'cause it's hurting so bad.
- Mm.
- Take it off.
- Now is that admitting defeat?
Did you feel like less of a man?
- At that point I was like--
- This is your version of taking the Uber.
- At this point I was like
I'm gonna have to call Claude,
I'm gonna have to tell him
he didn't get it right.
I'm gonna have to rent boots
for the rest of the week,
nullifying my whole purchase.
- You were gonna call
him and say screw you?
- No I was gonna call him and say, "Dude,
"I gotta get these
adjusted when I get back
"'cause it didn't work."
- Okay.
- But I put it back on
and said I'm gonna ski
the rest of the afternoon.
I get back out there, I also--
- You took it off,
you didn't see anything wrong with it?
I thought you were gonna say
he left a Dremel in there.
- No.
I take it off, nothing.
I mean I take it off and my
foot instantly feels better.
I put it back in there I'm like okay,
this is good, I'll get it tight.
Maybe it just needs to be tighter.
'Cause he told me it's gotta be tight,
you gotta get that thing tight in there.
'Cause they got it perfect,
so I get it super tight.
I ski a little bit more, I'm
having the time of my life.
Let me just tell you, I
took a little pain reliever
just to preemptively deal with the pain.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But we get down, we gotta
ski across the mountain
to get back to where we were staying.
The slopes close pretty early
there, around four o'clock.
And so we were gonna come
about 3:30 and come into the,
you literally, talk about being a douche,
I mean you ski directly down the hill
and you ski to the
valet guy for your hotel
and you just give him
your ski and you walk in,
he has hot chocolate, and
then you walk into your hotel.
- Is that right?
- It's all right there.
It's unbelievable,
it's the douchiest thing
you could possibly imagine.
And there's douches everywhere.
- Everywhere.
Everywhere you look, a douche.
- It's like lookin' in a mirror.
(chuckles)
- I mean people who ski in Vail,
this is as douchey as it gets, man,
as far as I've ever been around.
- Yeah yeah, you were lovin' it.
- And so--
- I can do it.
(Rhett laughs)
- We're skiing back
to, it's a big mountain
so we've got a lot of skiing to do
and I get to a place where I'm like
my foot is hurting me so
bad, but I can't show,
I can't feel how much
pain I'm in to my boys.
I gotta be the dad, I gotta hold this in.
- Yeah.
- But there was a couple
of times where we stopped,
where I would have to stop
and wait oh Shepherd
'cause he was still kinda
gettin' his legs and I would stop
and the pain would just shoot
from my heel all the way
up my leg and I would go (groans).
It would be a moment of (groans),
like crying out like
that and then I started--
- Your eyes cross?
- Then I started thinking
I may start crying I'm in so much pain.
I hadn't cried from pain
since I was a child.
(Link chuckles)
- Really?
- But my eyes were watering,
it was like oh gah!
And then Locke was like,
Dad, do we need to get help?
And I'm like, no son.
Your dad's gonna make it to
the bottom of the mountain.
- Your dad is a super douche.
His super tight-fitted custom boots
which don't amount to amount of crap.
- Your dad will not be out-douched by any
of the other douches around here.
Your dad is the douchiest dad. (chuckles)
- He's gonna cry but
he's gonna keep skiing
all the way to his valet and get that,
he's gonna grab that hot chocolate--
- With tears in his eyes.
- With his tears in his eyes.
(Rhett coughs)
- So--
- He's gonna retrieve
his testicles kept down
at the base of the mountain.
- I make it to the bottom of the mountain
and I'm in intense pain,
I get my hot chocolate
which makes me feel a little bit better.
I walk back to my room.
My wife is still out and about
doing whatever she wants.
I take off my boot.
And that, Link, is when--
- The end of your story.
- I did not know why I
didn't realize it before.
But the little windshield
wiper that he had given me
was in the bottom of my boot.
- No way!
- And I have--
- Even when I said like--
- No.
- I thought that you were
looking for something at the restaurant.
- This was in the bottom of my boot.
- Oh my gosh.
- And let me show you
what my foot looked like.
- Oh!
(Rhett laughs)
What?
- It was, okay--
- You paid so much money
for custom-fitted boots and then you put
a plastic windshield wiper
directly under your heel.
- Now you may think to yourself--
- How stupid.
- How could you not feel
that there was something under it?
- Yeah.
- And something about
the shape of this, the fact
that it was perfectly situated
in the bottom of my heel,
the fact that it has
absolutely no edge on one side
and then it is a perfect
circle and the fact
that I had experienced
almost the exact same type
of pain before, all these factors led me
to never consider that maybe the frickin'
Skigee they call it, that's
funny, squeegee, Skigee.
Is the thing that was sending
so much pain into my body.
- And it's weird how it
was literally sending it
directly up your heel.
- It was crazy.
- Like that's like an acupuncture
type situation, like--
- And the fact that I
made the decision early on
to be like, you know what,
it needs to be tighter.
(chuckles) That was when the pain--
- You ratcheted it down.
- Let me tell ya,
the rest of the trip, when
I didn't have that thing
in my boot, Claude.
Shout-out to you, brother.
You made my feet feel incredible.
I mean you shouldn't
have given me that Skigee
'cause I put it in my
boot, that was my fault,
but the repairs you made
to my boots were on point.
I don't need any adjustments.
I'm so happy.
It's the douchiest boots I've ever had.
This is one happy douche.
- And so that was day one.
- That was day one.
I'm glad I got that out of the way.
- Oh what if you'd realized
it at the end of the trip?
That'd have been horrible.
- Well it would have been
difficult to do because
I did look in my boot.
I didn't look at it in the
restaurant 'cause I didn't want
to even wanna draw attention to the fact
that I was taking my boot off.
- You were too concerned about your rep.
You didn't want all the
other douches to know
that you--
- Nobody else in
the restaurant had their boots on at all.
Nobody was even, well.
- Oh really?
- Anyway.
Skiing ended up being an
incredible part of the trip.
I did yell at my children a little bit
just to kinda join the club.
- It's interesting that, I mean,
you're the one who likes
variety and doesn't like
to go back and do the same thing.
I thought you're like man, this
skiing thing's getting old.
I wanna experience something different.
Are you doubling down on the skiing now?
- No, at the end of the trip,
my conclusion, and I
like to have a feeling
and to sort of distill a
feeling at the end of the trip,
and then kinda like remember that
because you'll forget about it.
It's just like when you have a child.
After you have a child
you're like I'm never doing
that again and then it wears
off and you have more kids.
- Yeah you didn't distill it enough.
- You gotta distill it.
Distilled at the end of
the vacation, I was like,
that was super fun but a couple things.
I feel like I narrowly avoided
getting seriously hurt.
Like just statistically speaking,
there was so much skiing involved for me
and my two sons that the fact
that none of us got hurt,
I kinda feel like we got lucky
'cause there was people getting
on our plane in wheelchairs
and they had been recently injured.
- Wow.
- During their time in Vail.
And also yeah, you do kinda feel like
I've kinda been down this trail.
And because I'm not some super risk-taker,
I don't like to jump off of cliffs,
my skiing experience sort of maxes out
with a certain thing and so,
and also Jessie didn't do it with us
and so I kinda felt like I wasn't spending
that much time with her so
I thought, you know what--
- So you're saying this
phase is coming to an end?
- No no no, no I think
that the weekend ski trip,
the two day, the three day ski trip,
but a full week of skiing in one place.
We're not gonna do it next year,
we're gonna do something
else, and then we'll decide
as a family if we wanna
go back and do it again.
Had an incredible time and the kids,
one of the things about
doing that much skiing back
to back is like, the learning curve.
The kids are so much better.
Shepherd can keep up with us perfectly now
because he just did so much skiing.
- Well you know I agree that you should
distill down your trip.
I think for me as it relates
to the trip, you know,
I had all the expectations
of what the perfect trip
would look like from an
itinerary standpoint.
On the fifth day we went
to Stonehenge and Bath.
And then just to give you a complete view
of what my trip was, I do
recommend going to Stonehenge.
I know you're into, it's not wood,
but you're also into rocks--
- Yeah stones.
- You're into like 5,000
year old rock configurations.
Very cool.
Bath was okay.
(piano music)
Tastes like bad pipes.
Was cool to walk around but
I really loved Stonehenge.
But as far as distilling it down,
I also think I had a lot of expectations,
I got really excited the
months back when I said
this is gonna be like sweet 16, Lily trip.
I don't know what I pictured specifically
but I will be honest, and
this is not a criticism
of Lily in any way, I
think it's more of just
my internal dialogue that I don't know,
I felt like there was
gonna be some magical,
sweet 16 moment that I
found myself questioning.
Should I have done
something more ceremonial?
Like when we went to
Bath and Bath is the only
naturally occurring
hot springs in the U.K.
in that one town and they
built a whole, you know,
town around it.
People come forever and
just drink from the springs
and they started bathing in it.
I was like maybe I should do some sort
of sweet 16 ceremony here--
- I'm sure that would go over well.
- Yeah it's like, that was
not my instinct at the time
but then when it was
done, we were coming back,
I was like, could it have
been even more special?
I think I was thinking, I don't know,
that there would all of
a sudden, the structure
or the tone of our entire
relationship would shift.
I ultimately chalked it up
to me having these nebulous
but huge and unrooted
expectations of some magical event
happening where oh look,
my daughter is a woman now
and I guess that's not the
right way to say it. (chuckles)
But like, that we'd have
this special moment,
like remember that one
moment when she turned to me
and her mom and said, "You know what,
"you're the greatest parents
on Earth and I am so,
"I just feel like I'm having
the most special moment
"of my life right now and
I'm glad that I'm sharing it
"with you and not with
some two-bit boyfriend
"who wants to take me to some
knock-off prom situation."
- Knock-off prom?
- I don't know I'm just--
- What is that?
- There is no
two-bit boyfriend and
there's no knock-off prom,
I'm just saying like, you
know as your kids get older,
at least for me, I want to
know that I have a vibrant
and special relationship as it evolves,
because make no mistake, it is evolving.
She's becoming an adult.
So it's not a parent-child
relationship exclusively,
now it's like a, there's
a friend component,
there's starting to have
conversations that you would have
with any other adult and seeing her rise
to that occasion
conversationally and say oh yeah,
I'm seeing my daughter differently,
as a more mature person
who's becoming her own
complete adult, you know?
That's really starting
to happen at this point
in an emotional, relational level.
But I apparently had
some sort of expectation
that there would be a magical moment.
- That only happens in the movies, man.
That happens on television.
That doesn't happen in real life.
- And to your point, if you
tried to ceremonialize it,
it could go very sideways.
It could be very awkward, you can't,
so I kinda swung the pendulum
upon further reflection
that if I would have
tried to create some sort
of ceremonial moment like
manufacture it or engineer it,
that the chances of that
backfiring into awkwardness
and just seeming forced, there's
a high likelihood of that.
So I think my takeaway in having
been awhile since the trip
is just an appreciation
that we did the trip.
I think as more time passes,
it will actually grow
to be even more special.
That's my theory at least,
that you take the while time
as a whole and it's not,
the picture that we took in
front of Westminster Abbey
when it started hailing on us,
maybe that'll be a great memory too.
I think it will be, but
it's coming back after going
to the Harry Potter tour all
day and riding in some huge
frickin' torturous bus for over an hour
to get to this place and to come back
and then just crashing at our
room and saying you know what,
let's just watch
something, and she's like,
let's watch The Umbrella,
let's see, what's it called?
Umbrella Academy.
It's a series on Netflix that she's into.
She's like I've already watched it
but I wanna watch it with you guys.
So it's like all three
of us piling into our bed
and watching a Netflix series together.
And I think those are the
things that I'm gonna remember,
it's like, we hung out like friends
and it was special and even,
they may remember me having the breakdown.
And I think we'll be able
to laugh about those type
of things but I think it's--
- It's an investment, man.
- It's an investment
in setting an environment
where we can have
an experience together so that
the weird, the frustrating, the tired,
and the special all kinda meld together
and create something that
I believe is unforgettable
but doesn't translate into
something you can just buy
in a souvenir shop and
remember in that way.
- It's not like something,
it's like investing
into your retirement
fund and then going back
the next day and looking at
it and being like oh, oh.
When is this gonna grow?
- I think that's right.
- Because I mean--
- And I also think
from her perspective, it's
not like, I expected her
to articulate things that--
- Kids don't do that.
- As a 16 year old, she
has no point of reference.
I didn't wanna go into
this lecture moment,
like not every 16 year old
gets to go anywhere they want
in the world and you get to go to London
and don't forget what we've done for you.
It's like I actually was
tempted to go into that
a few times but--
- Well you should do that
from time to time just to be a good dad.
- Not that she wasn't
grateful or appreciative
because she was but--
- You just have to hope
that when the kids write
the tell-all book--
- Uh-huh.
- That the good outweighs the bad, man.
And the best you can hope
for is that you're gonna get
like a card.
Okay, realistically,
you're gonna get a card
when they're 33.
- Okay.
- And they've got some life
experience and they're like,
they write you a really
sweet card and they're like,
I remember that trip and
I really thought about
how you cared about us
and the time that you put
into our relationship,
but unless you've got
an exceptionally exceptional,
unusual, expressive child,
they're not gonna be
like, I wanna let you know
that this vacation is
going incredibly well
and I recognize--
- Right.
- That you guys have
actually thought about this
in a way that, I realize
this is just for me.
You guys made a decision to
leave the other kids at home,
to just bring me here to do
the things that I wanted to do,
to create a memory for me.
You guys are the best
parents in the world.
- Yeah that's what I wanted
and that would be weird,
wouldn't it?
- You don't want that
because then it's about you.
- Mm.
Isn't that true.
- It's not about you,
it's about the investment
that you're making in your
daughter and your family--
- That's right.
- And then you gotta hope
that not only is it, first
of all, you don't do it
just for the card or for the tell-all book
to be good versus bad, you're doing it
because you actually
think it's contributing
to her as a person.
- And how can she know?
How could she even process?
At my age, I can barely
process the way that
my experiences are impacting who I am.
- Yeah you take me for
granted all the time.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- No I mean I deal with the
same things with my kids.
No, I do on a regular
basis and also think that,
generalization here but,
dealing with two boys is
a little bit different.
(sighs) They are constantly fighting
and constantly annoying each other
and we had to, there were multiple times
where I'm just like--
(grunting angrily)
Going to that kinda Dad mode, you know.
And then I have to pull myself back.
But you talk about you
guys getting together.
One of the most special
things that we experienced
on our trip was, okay so every day,
three of us would go out and ski.
There would be multiple
fights between Locke
and Shepherd because Locke's getting mad
that Shepherd's holding
us up and he falls down
and he needs help and other
people have to help him
if I'm below him on
the mountain and stuff,
and then Locke'll be like,
I'm gonna ski by myself.
And so he goes off and
does his teenage ski
by himself thinking
that Shepherd and I ski
and then we'll meet up.
You 'bout to do that?
You gonna come down that?
- [Shepherd] Which way are we going?
- Oh, nothing.
So that kind of thing is happening.
I'm kinda trying to manage
it and I'm not trying
to force it because I want the same thing.
I want there to be these moments of like,
a father and his two
sons in perfect rhythm
on the slopes of Colorado.
- Yeah.
- Postcard.
- But really it's--
- And while they're skiing
they're looking at you
talking about how great of a dad you are.
- Yeah, right, but really
what's happening is
I'm getting separated from Shepherd
and I'm getting a phone call from Jessie
who got a phone call from the
guy at the lift who's like,
your son is here and is lost.
That happened, yeah, it's
not even worth (chuckles).
- Shepherd or Locke?
- Shepherd.
Locke had his own phone,
but Shepherd was fine.
He didn't panic or anything,
he knew that we would get
in touch when we got back up.
And also in the midst
of looking for Shepherd,
cutting off this little girl
and her dad come skiing up
to me and he's like what
the hell were you thinking?
And me not saying anything back to him
because I didn't have an answer.
- There's something in my boot.
- No that was after the boot had been--
- There was something
in my boot yesterday.
- But the cool, one of the
best things that happened
as a family is we would go skiing
and then we would come back
and we would go out to eat.
And then we would come back to the hotel
and they had their room
and we had our room.
But we would all get into
our bed so four of us,
which is even more difficult
than three people in a bed
and we would watch The Goldbergs.
Now I know--
- The Goldbergs.
- I've already plugged The Goldbergs once.
But--
- You pluggin' some Goldbergs.
That was your show.
- And again,
let me just say that I'm not saying
that it's a perfect show, I'm
saying it is the perfect show
to watch as our family
because we all fit these
totally exaggerated tropes and
the show is so exaggerated,
well not really, I mean it's--
- You don't have to go back through why
The Goldbergs is great but
what did it do for you guys?
- No but we relate, there's
something about all this stuff
that we've done during
the day of Locke being
the typical teenager and Shepherd being
the typical annoying little brother
and Jessie being the overprotective mom
and me being the fad with a short fuse--
- Uh-huh.
- That when you sit down
and you see it played out
comedically in a show,
we start realizing how we've
just fallen into these roles
in these predictable ways
and it just makes us,
we bonded as a family
and then like Shepherd,
it'd be like 10 o'clock at night
and Shepherd figured out
how to call room to room
of course so we started doing that a lot.
The phone would ring, I'd
pick it up and be like hello
and Shepherd would be like,
you know what time it is.
I was like what, he said, "Goldberg time."
(laughs) So he was like,
he was so into us--
- That's good.
- Sitting down
and there's not a--
- It's kinda like
our Survivor time.
- Like you've said before,
there's not a lot of
entertainment out there
that you can just sit down as a family
and just completely bond.
That used to be the way it was.
- Yeah.
- Ironically back in the 80s
which is when The Goldbergs is based but
that was the sweetest time that we had.
Lots of typical family stuff that we did
of getting on each other's nerves
but there was that time
we would all get together,
all file into the bed and just,
I think that that's the kinda thing
that they're gonna remember.
- Yeah.
- They're gonna have a memory of like,
I remember being, you don't
remember being annoyed
by your little brother or your big brother
or your dad having a short
fuse or your mom picking
at something on you and upsetting you.
I think you remember
those, the sweet times.
- And if they don't, we can
make 'em listen to this podcast.
- You have anything else from London?
- No that's it, man.
We rode the double-decker bus.
Christy liked that a lot
better than the Tube.
A lot more visibility.
Everybody was happy--
- On top?
- Once we get up top of
the double-decker bus.
- I have a quick rec that I think
you're gonna whole-heartedly agree with.
♪ Check baby check baby
one two three four ♪
♪ Check baby check baby ♪
- I do--
♪ One two ♪
- Just as a small addendum because
I can't not tell you this.
In the little shop in Vail--
- There's a rec?
- This is a--
- You teased the rec.
- I'm teasing the rec.
- Okay.
- In the little shop in Vail,
Vail Village, well in Vail
Village there's a bunch of shops
and there's a bunch of
really rich folk stuff.
- They call those boutiques.
- And we went into this
one store called Gorsuch,
which I just thought that he was the guy
that Obama tried to get to be
the Supreme Court nominee.
- Neil Gorsuch.
- It didn't work out too well.
But apparently it's a
brand or it's a store.
And you could kinda tell from the window
that this was like douche central.
And so we're like let's go--
- You were like a moth to a flame.
- Well here's the thing.
I'll get custom ski
boots but I don't go in
and buy unnecessarily expensive clothing.
I don't do that.
- Like a vest
with like skiers on it.
- I don't do that.
So we go into this place.
- You went in.
- For entertainment purposes,
I'm not gonna buy anything.
I'm going in there because I'm blown away
at the culture and like the
vibe and it's three stories.
- I think the collars won't un-pop there.
- We go in there, you walk in,
the first level is the women's level.
- Okay.
- And there was this
coat that was like a cardigan of some kind
but a little bit longer.
- I think that's just a coat.
- Nothing special, looks
like something from the rack
of Forever 21.
- Okay.
- Price tag.
- $2,000.
- $3,998.
- Good gosh.
- $4,000 and I was like
what?
And I was like I'm gonna be in here awhile
because this is so entertaining to me.
And there's people actually
shopping and trying things on.
I go upstairs to the men's
section and that was when,
and I'd already kinda picked up on this,
there's a bunch of Italian people.
Lots of people from Europe,
lots of people speaking Spanish
and Italian.
- Okay.
- But lots of Italian people
who apparently have lots of--
- Money.
- Discretionary cash.
- Gettin' that Italian leather.
- And this dude is trying
on this puffy jacket
in front of his girlfriend.
How do I look?
But he said it in Italian,
and she was like--
- But you knew that's what he was saying.
- She was like--
- Bonjour.
- Bonito, well, I don't know.
- That's French.
- What is the, I don't know.
She said it looked good.
And then I went and I picked one up.
- Oh you kinda on the sly looked at--
- $2,000.
It was just a puffy jacket.
This dude was about to buy it.
I mean, this place--
- Welcome to your future.
- But here's the thing--
- Listen man.
All right so you're on record saying
you would never do this 'cause
you're on a slippery slope
with your hot chocolate.
- Well hold on no, first of all,
ski boots cost what ski boots cost, right?
- Okay.
- In the long run, I'm
actually gonna save money
because you have to rent
'em every time you go.
- Okay.
- But the thing I told Jessie
is I was like, I don't--
- You know me, I'm a tight wad, man.
I bought the Oyster card, it's
got $5 on it, I can't Uber.
- No but let's just say
you had unlimited money.
Money was not an object which is a saying
which I've never understood
exactly that means literally
but money is no obstacle to you, right.
- Yeah.
- You wouldn't buy the, if I
had all the money in the world,
I would not buy a $4,000 jacket.
I would buy $2,000--
- If it did something.
- It doesn't do anything else.
- If it did something very
special like told the future,
then you'd probably buy it but
you're not just gonna buy one
that doesn't tell the future.
- But apparently this
stuff is so expensive
that Americans can't even buy it.
You gotta be Italian.
- Oh.
- You gotta be rich and
from another country.
You know what I'm saying, like,
'cause I was the only
American that ventured
into this particular shop.
- Maybe the dollar
conversion is confusing.
- And there's (chuckles),
and there's something
about Italians doing it
that makes it seem not douchey.
- They can do anything.
- You know what I'm saying,
it's like, he's kinda
making himself seem humble
in that $2,000 (laughing).
- Yeah.
- $2,000 jacket.
I could never get away with that.
- Every time they get in the
car they're magically driving
on an undulating highway on the coast.
- Right.
- That's how Italians roll.
- I don't understand where
the money comes from.
- Every road.
- It's like Italian royalty
but that's not a thing
'cause it's not a monarchy.
I don't know where it comes from.
Pasta money, that's what it is.
- They just churn it out like pasta.
- Yeah.
- They just extrude money.
- So anyway.
- Like bow tie pasta.
- Shout out to the non-douchey,
very rich Italians of Vail.
May your $4,000 jackets
keep you warm at night.
- What's your recommendation, man?
- My recommendation is a song that
actually you played for me.
I do wanna say quickly that--
- You gonna recommend a song.
- I made a recommendation,
a musical recommendation
that we had to cut out
because the person I recommended
said something problematic
so I'm not, and I already
said that on Twitter but--
- You talkin' about Cardi B?
- No it wasn't Cardi B.
It was a lesser, very lesser known person.
- You talking about Michael Jackson?
- No, now you're just saying things.
It was somebody that you
probably didn't know about.
- Controversial artist.
- No and I'm saying that
me mentioning them to
like 90% of you would be
your first time you'd ever
heard this person's name
and then you'd look them
up and you'd see the thing
they're in the news for now
is something problematic
so that's why we took the rec out.
- You're about to make
the same mistake again?
- No I'm giving you a very
non-problematic music rec.
- Don't rec the same guy.
- This is not a guy, this is a group.
And this is a group that
my son and I bonded over
because I played this particular song
and I feel like I opened
up a world to my son
and he actually ended up texting me today
about this whole movement of
music that we talked about
and that is Make It With You by Bread.
Which I think is--
- Oh I love the song.
- Is on the post concert
playlist that you put together.
- Yeah I've been big
on this song for awhile
'cause a matter of fact,
Spotify played it in the car
the other day and Lily was
like, you play this song a lot.
So she didn't seem to love Bread.
- Okay well my boy was into it.
And so Make It With You by Bread.
Bread is a soft rock band
that I think that song's
from like 73 or 74 but early 70s,
almost as a--
- Hey.
- Rebellion against--
- Have you ever tried
really reaching out for the other side?
- As a rebellion against the
sort of the disco movement
that was happening, these
guys were doing something,
they were just pouring out
their music like syrup.
- Well they were climbing on rainbows.
- It was absolutely amazing
and this song, dare I say,
there are no perfect songs
but if you had to put songs
into closest to perfect
as it can possibly be,
Make It With You by Bread is a as close
to perfect song as there is.
- Oh man those are strong words.
I think it's--
- And listen to it with your
ear phones on (chuckles).
- Your ear biscuits.
It's like Summer Breeze
but a little less douchey.
So it's not like, it's like
the Italian Summer Breeze.
- It's like the Italian Summer Breeze.
- Yeah I agree with that.
- It's like putting on a $4,000 jacket
and then realizing that oh,
I didn't even pay for this.
- All right guys, we're
gonna wrap this up.
Thanks for going with us
on a journey back through
our experiences over spring break.
Vote for us for the Webby if you want to.
Or leave a, if it's past
that and you're listening
to this in the distant future
you can still leave a review
on iTunes if that still happens.
If that still exists in the future.
How far in the future are
you listening to this?
- I don't know.
- I'm glad it's
still in the ether.
- Somebody's listening to this in 2031.
- Our great grandchildren.
- 2031's not,
hopefully we won't have
great grandchildren by then.
- Well.
- I mean it might be biologically possible
but it would be controversial
to say the least.
That's like 12 years from now.
- That's a good point.
(Rhett chuckles)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)